All righty, dude, it's done.
Amazing.
Another episode in the bag.
That was such a good interview.
Cosmin is just such a smart dude, such an amazing person to talk to.
My alarm just went off.
Sorry.
Yeah, man.
Yeah, no, I think that was one of the best episodes we've ever recorded, to be honest.
That was pretty sick.
Yeah.
Yeah, that was amazing.
I mean, there are so many hackers that we could have talked to at this event, and we
had picked just ahead of time, like, let's talk to Cosmin, and then we ended up winning
the belt.
Yeah, dude.
We nailed it.
We pulled off the belt, and it was actually an amazing performance as well.
Yeah.
I don't know that we get to talk too much about it on the pod episode, but, yeah, just
multi-tenant, multi-target live hacking events is just a total skill of itself, and Cosmin's
the best at it.
Yep.
It's such a beast.
You have to be so skilled and so flexible in your skill set to be able to pull it off.
It's just amazing.
Yeah, absolutely.
All right.
Well, I mean, I guess we don't have too much to say before they get into the episode, but,
yeah, if you guys would check out criticalthinkingpodcast.io, we have the newsletter over there.
Drop your email, and let me see, what is Cosmin's Twitter really quickly?
Yeah.
I think it's, I want to say it's inhibitor181 on Twitter.
I believe it is.
Yeah.
Cosmin is Cosmin, legendary hacker.
Definitely give him a follow.
And, yeah, enjoy the episode.
Yeah.
We've talked a lot about like going deep, right?
And like how, if you pick any kind of target...
Excuse me, Joel.
Getting intimate with the application.
Yeah, sorry.
Right.
So like, as you get more and more...
I just realized that would end up going deep, which is when you put it with getting...
I'm sorry, go ahead.
Yeah.
Well, we're going deep and getting intimate.
Yeah, it's going deep and getting intimate, man.
excuse me Joel, getting intimate with the application. Right, so like as you get more and more. I just realized how we end up going deep with this when you put it with getting, I'm sorry go ahead. Yeah, well we're going deep and getting intimate. Yeah, it's going deep and getting intimate man. Okay, I'll play you that.
Dude, here we are. Welcome to the pod. Thank you. Yeah. I just want to say before we get started on this, we contacted Cosmin before the event and we said, hey, we're going to record a session. You want to join us? And he agreed. And then he proceeded to win the MVH for the live hacking event. So, there you go.
Thank you. Very good man. Congratulations. It was the most insane timing because we were just, we had planned like days in advance that we were going to take, put you on the pod and then we were just like, we watched you win and then we said to each other, I guess we picked a good guess.
Placed the right bets man. So, so this is, this is your, this is your second MVH, right? Yeah, second.
Hey, amazing. Two MVH squad. It is now, it is now me, you, Franz and Josh.
Joe Hash. Joe Hash. But as we discussed yesterday, um, Cosmin has a little bit of a unique feature for his two MVHs. You have, um, two MVHs on live hacking events with two targets.
Yes.
That's tricky, man. Yeah.
How does, how does, how does that work? Like, I feel like you have to split your time between the two targets because in order to get selected for MVH in a two target event, you have to find great bugs on both targets, right?
Yeah, usually, usually like that. Like, doesn't mean that you have to like, look at all the scopes of each program and you have to pick a part of the scope for each program, you know?
Yeah.
And, uh, go deep, try to find something that works out or not.
Yeah. So, we, we won't say who it is or what it is, but there is a thing that you specialize in that you are much better at than everybody else.
And, um, at our, at the event that we just did here, here in London, there were two targets and somehow you managed to spend, find your specialty on both, on both targets.
Yeah.
Which is impressive.
You did a show and tell and in the first show and tell you're like, yeah, so I'm clicking through and, uh, and I noticed this checkbox and there's like two options and what just says name of the thing that you're specializing in and some other thing.
And I was like, of course, that's, that's, that's really sick. And I think the advice that you, that you gave right there, I mean, that's definitely applicable, um, for winning multiple, multiple, uh, target live hacking events, you know, getting an NVH for that.
But I think that's really applicable to most live hacking events as well. It's like, a lot of the time you, you get these large companies that say, yeah, just like hack us in general. Right.
And everyone's like, holy crap. I got to like run around and like try all these different pieces of scope, see which one's vulnerable. And then like, but no, really, I think my experience, it's been best to just pick one part of the scope, stick to it.
And just, if you pick the wrong thing, like it's fine because at the end of the day, you're going to be less scattered than anyone else trying to run around. Is that kind of what you do?
Yeah, for sure. For sure. Just pick something that you like and, uh, just go with it and you can win, you can lose. You have no idea. It's like, it could be like super hardened or a pretty shallow scope, like apparently life scope, but shallow. So you don't have any idea, but, uh, I don't think, uh, for me personally, it's not a good idea to focus, uh, on the whole scope.
Yeah. Because you don't have time to go deep and you have a big chance of a dupe. Like for this event, I had just one dupe.
One dupe. Wow. Dang, that's pretty sick, man. Yeah, you're awesome. Yeah, so it's really interesting because I was thinking like, we've talked a lot about like going deep, right? And like how, if you pick any kind of target.
Excuse me, Joel, getting into it with the application.
Sorry. Right. So like, as you get more and more. I just realized how you end up going deep, which is when you put it with getting, I'm sorry, go ahead.
Yeah. Well, we're going deep and getting into it. Yeah, it's going deep and getting into it. Man, okay, lovely.
Yeah. Um, but like you can kind of apply that to any, any type of, like if you just like focus in and you learn intimately, like how stuff is working, like what are the different pieces? What are the different aspects of the application? How do they communicate together?
You can build out that solid understanding and find the really, really deep bugs. But you've managed to do this with a technology that is so widely used that it's like, it's almost program and targeted agnostic, right? So you, so you can just be like, this target uses technology.
Yeah. I know technology. Yeah. Let's go. Right. Right. It's almost like learning like SQL injection. It's almost like a generic kind of knowledge at this point because it's so widely used and you're so familiar with it. Like I would reckon you're probably
more knowledgeable than employees. Oh, I mean, I'm sure they've tried. I mean, well, okay, we, we won't, we won't go down that path, but I'd imagine you've gotten some, some job, you know, offers from X, X company that we're, that we're talking about.
But, um, yeah, no, and I think, but going back to live hacking event strategy, I think when you do pick a specific, like part of the application, it's really easy to think like, oh man, like I've picked the wrong part of the application.
I mean, I had that same mentality during this event, like, oh shoot. Like I definitely, especially when you see the report counts go up for other people and you're, and you've maybe just got like a couple of highs or something like that.
It's really hard to think about that. So how do you deal with the, with the mental piece of it? And do you struggle at all with like, oh man, um, you know, imposter syndrome and I'm not finding the bones in the right part of the application.
Yeah. Yeah. So for sure this, uh, this, this, this happens, this happens. Yeah. Um, but, uh, I, I usually persist.
Yeah. Just push through it. Yeah. Just push through it, go through it. Uh, and it usually actually pays off.
Absolutely. I totally agree. Yeah. Because, uh, there's like, sometimes the, it's really hard to set up the, all the tools, the, the programs and it's a pain.
And after you do it, it's like a new venue is open for you to find like stuff and can really change really fast.
You can go really down, but then it's a huge up. Yeah.
Oh yeah. No, go ahead. Go ahead and mute it before it gets, uh, it gets too beepy.
Sam is going to blow, be blowing up your DMs right in the middle of it.
Yeah. No, no, that, that makes sense, man. And I think it is, it's, it, that's a big part of bug downing.
I think that's underestimated is that sort of mental toughness that's required to kind of push through,
you know, and, and I, you, you see this and I'm sure you, you all get the DMS as well, but I get a bunch
of DMS every week from, from people. Do you, do you have your DMS open on Twitter or no?
No, I have them. I have them open.
Yeah. So like, so many DMS from people being like, how do I find these bugs? And I'm like, well,
you sit down and then you try to hack it and then you fail and then you try to hack it and then you
fail and then you try to hack it and then you fail and you complete, you do that like 20 times until
you actually find a bug. And after anywhere from three to 30 days, it'll click.
Exactly.
Yeah. Yeah. So I actually wanted to like, since you've been hacking on the same, like the same type
of technology for like so, so long, um, I have a couple of questions. One, is there stuff that like
still surprises you? Like new stuff that you learn as you're hacking that you didn't know before? Or is
it pretty much like very predictable at this point? Yeah. So it depends. Like some facts are really
predictable. Like, you know, what's going on and you can imagine what they use, how they use, you know,
it should not be vulnerable. So you can just like look a bit, try to understand it like on the big
picture. Uh, but also new parts are added. Like you have maybe like a new API, you have something
you exposed. I'm sure that's exciting. Yeah. And like it adds to the pieces of the puzzle for the
for the whole image. So I think it's a little bit of both. Sometimes it's tedious, sometimes it's exciting,
but you can't have everything. Do you have to stretch yourself to look for new innovative volumes in that
rather than just going back to your, you know, bread and butter, your, your default for that,
for that, for this target or, you know, is that something that comes pretty naturally?
Uh, so I think I do it consciously. So sometimes I go back to my brother, brother and butter. Sometimes I
try to like the goal deep in a very specific piece of that and do some research. Sometimes I spend like
weeks just trying to understand something, trying to go deeper and learn it. And then, um, I can apply
it to like a really big scope. So you have to like, I personally consciously choose what to do because I also
try to imagine how would that be applicable to the big picture. So do you, do you like intentionally
have like, cause once, once you've been working on one target for so long, I feel like in the
beginning, when you're introduced to a target, you're just trying to like get in the zone. You're
trying to get the feel for the application, the lay of the land. But then once you've been on a target
for so long, do you have to have like planning meetings with yourself and be like, all right,
in, in one week, I'm going to like check in and be like, all right, do I need to pivot or do I need to
stay or like set goals? Or is it mostly just sort of on the fly? Like, okay, I'm kind of spinning my
wheels here. I'm not getting anywhere. Um, you know, I should, maybe I should pivot. How does that work
for you? Yeah. So for sure, I don't do anything like I'm not a psychopath. So my notes are in text files.
So nothing special. That's another big topic we've talked about is notes, but we'll, we'll come back to that.
Yeah. So, uh, definitely, I think it's, uh, how I feel like on the mental level, uh, like if I try
to do something that doesn't work, doesn't work, I, I just try to change it and do the other thing.
Yeah. You know, but then, okay. But, and this is another common question that I get all the time.
Where do you draw the line for that? Like, how do you know, do you, do you have any methodology or is it
just gut to when to draw the line? And I was trying to quantify it the other day, because I, we get this
question a lot. Like, where do you, where do you decide, okay, this is the work I need to move on
versus persisting. And I think for me, it's like probably five or six mental iterations of,
I actually can't find anything else here or like, I'm something, I feel like I've hit a wall. And then
I try to push through like maybe five times before I thought, okay, actually I need to move on.
Well, and I think like that, that point you made like mental iterations is like really important,
right? It's not like, it's not like attempts, right? Cause I was talking with some other hackers
at this event specifically about race conditions. And like, there was one race condition that somebody
found where they were like, yeah, it was like one in 25 that it hit.
Okay. Okay. But that guy's kind of nuts though.
Yes.
But he's kind of crazy.
He is a little bit crazy.
Like, so maybe that's what you need, a little bit of crazy.
Yeah. Like there's just, I think with some bugs, there's just like, you have a gut instinct and
you can't explain why, but you can just feel it. That it works. Right. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. For sure.
For sure. Yeah. Yeah. So, I mean, what do you think for you? Like mental iterations wise,
or how do you tell when to give up on a certain path or continue down?
Uh, yeah, I think it's a gut thing also. I don't think I do that many iterations, but I usually come
back to the same logic.
Oh, really?
I would crush myself into some more iterations.
Oh.
Yeah. So like, actually, in one of the bugs I presented, I did some iterations, it did not work.
Then I went out.
The second one or the first one for us?
Uh, the first one.
Because he, this fricker had, this fricker had NBH and over two show, like two show and tells.
And I'm just like, on both nights, which I think probably won in the NBH.
Yeah. It's kind of crazy.
And so basically, I tried to do something, it did not work.
Then I went, uh, outside to go walk without thinking.
No, I'm sorry.
Was it show and tell one or two?
One. Okay.
I figured.
Yeah, yeah.
I thought it's a two.
Yeah.
Okay.
I would try that.
And it worked.
Like, I was actually thinking about it, so.
Wait, okay.
So, so, yeah.
Walk me through your thought process.
Do you try to approach it as like an employee?
Or how are you thinking about it when you're, when you're churning in your head
about those iterations and what things you, if it's not working,
do you want to try next?
Is, are you trying to think like, how is this written?
Or is it more like, what things have I seen before that it might be vulnerable to?
Or like, how are you thinking about that?
Yeah.
So, this particular case you're talking to, right?
Uh, yeah.
So, I pretty much knew what was going on in the background, so it was pretty clear in my head
exactly what was going on because I could confirm it to like from various tests.
Right, right, right.
You have seen like the short version of that.
I have, yeah.
Um, and I just, uh, first I thought about what can I do there?
What can I do there?
So, I just went a bit to the documentation.
Yeah.
I left and then, uh, read the documentation.
Freaking docs.
Read the docs.
Yeah.
And, uh, it just hit me like, I don't know, subconsciously.
It's a couple, a couple of comments on this.
One, he said, you said you went outside and you did some work, right?
That is big.
That is, that is really big.
Like you can definitely, that is definitely something that gets the juices flowing and gets creativity rolling.
I don't know about you, but like the best place for me to think is on the toilet.
Oh.
Like shower, toilet, hot tub.
Shower thoughts, toilet thoughts.
Shower goes so good, yeah.
Shower's good, right?
Yeah.
Like I, I tell you man, you guys got to invest in the hot tub.
Like I always, whenever I'm, I'm, I mean, I seriously mean it.
It is an investment, man.
I have made money off of that hot tub.
It's like an elevated shower.
Because you get, you get in the hot tub and you just start like levitating.
Like, and then you just like ascend to higher levels of bug bounty, I think.
Um, no, but, but that's really good.
And, and I think when it comes to gut related stuff, right?
You, that, that, we, we try to quantify it just to be clear for all of you that are listening,
being like, don't tell me it's gut.
Like, no, I don't know.
Yeah, but this also comes with experience for sure.
Right.
That's exactly what I was going to say.
You have to put in the reps to get the gut.
Right.
It's like that combination of, of you have to be like consuming knowledge and stuff.
Because if you, if you just learn, like imagine you're in school, right?
You learn everything up to like the 12th grade and then you never learn anything again.
You're never going to like go beyond that.
Right.
Because you just, you have to keep consuming and learning new things if you want to progress.
And so that applies to like bug bounty in the same way where like if there's a technology
or anything that you're hacking, like if you just stop, like that's as limited as you're
going to be.
You're, if you don't learn new techniques, if you don't learn about how technologies work,
then that's it.
That's where you're going to end.
And like, that might be good for you, but like, yeah, this is how you get two FBHs.
Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
And on one hand, I think, I think the gut answer might be annoying for most people, but
I feel like that's how most people do, most successful hackers do respond.
It's like, oh, I just somehow felt it, that it was there, you know?
Yeah.
But on the other hand, I feel like that should be reassuring as well, because at the end
of the day, there's no like crazy methodology you've got to train yourself to stick
to.
It's just, you've got to just do it a lot.
Right.
So, right.
I mean, do you agree?
Yeah, for sure, for sure, for sure.
Like if I think in this moment with the current knowledge I have, I missed dozens of dozens
of bugs in the beginning.
Oh yeah.
I didn't have like that.
Yeah.
Got experience and stuff like that.
Oh, absolutely.
So you mentioned that you use text files for notes.
I recently started using Notion actually for notes, just because like you can,
you can have sub pages and stuff.
We've talked about how Joel is a freak about organization.
Like, okay.
So recently I was like, I just, I just felt like a great system for me because I can have
like one large thing that's like hacker one or whatever.
And then underneath that, I can create one for like whatever program I'm hacking on.
And then I can just do bullets and unstructured stuff.
And I can just toss like brain dumps in there, little snippets and stuff.
Right.
So is it literally just like TXT files for you?
Okay.
Yeah.
Basically, no.
So when you say TXT files, you make it sound elevated.
So you say TXT files.
There's no extension.
No, with like different topics in the same file.
Oh, it basically says files.
It says files.
It's file.
I do like to imagine it's just like a 2500 line.
No, no, no.
So basically, he opens notepad and just ctrl F.
So look, I, okay.
So just aside, I have like seven text files.
Oh, okay.
One is called literally notes.
The other one is tricks.
Tricks.
The other one is mobile.
Nice.
And the other two have my program name in it.
Yeah.
One and two.
And that's why I have a problem.
Yeah.
Because sometimes I don't know in which file it is.
He doesn't even like it.
I have to grab it.
So in case you're wondering, we're all really high-tech organized people.
It's about seven text files away.
Yeah, for, yeah, man.
I mean, it just makes me feel better about like, you know, when you hear stuff like this,
or you hear Eric talk about like, and I think he's been pretty public about this,
but like he uses VBA, you know.
Eric being today is new.
You know, just, you know, the whole, he's one of the most, you know, amazing automation hackers
out there, but he's, his system, and he'll acknowledge it is just totally like taped together
with like, you know, SGP and like, and then Cosmin, you know, the, the, the legend of a
one program master takes notes in like one, one file called notes and one file called tricks.
If you want to hear something really funny, you should see how I name my book projects.
I can't do ASDF anymore.
Oh my gosh, dude.
That's, that's psychopathic behavior right there.
If I have something really interesting and I have to start the new project, like for this event,
I started like five, five projects, but yeah, I, I literally named the name
on the project is interesting.
So I know in the drop-down list, it's not, it's not, it's not.
Oh my gosh.
And when I open it, it goes to the top.
So I have to reopen the other one.
Oh my gosh, Cosmin, what is wrong with you, man?
That's so good.
Okay.
So I definitely don't do that with the burp files.
Like I intentionally name all my burp files.
So I know where my requests are, Cosmin, but like, I definitely do that same thing
when I'm like creating multiple objects in a, in a, you know, an actual software that
I'm trying to hack, like I'll name, like, like for example, you know, there's like various
documents in one of the targets we were working on.
And every time I was like, you know, ASDF, ASDF, then it like has the same one.
And then I'll forget which like one I'm trying to attack in a specific
scenario.
So then I'll just rename one of them this one.
And then I'll do that like three times.
So there's like four named this one.
And then it's like, no, really this one, you know, like I used to do that with all my payloads
too, where I would just be like test, test two, test three, test four.
And then eventually I was like, I can't, I need to like start naming these like real names
because I'll come back to a program after like a year and I'll, I'll see all my old files.
And I'm like, I have no idea what these are.
Yeah.
Like I was, I was going back to a program yesterday and I had a, I had one file
called this shit is really interesting.burp.
I was like, Oh my God.
What is that?
I don't even know.
Great job, self.
You click baited me.
All right.
I'll check it out.
Now it's funny though, because you know, and I, I was working with, with Sean, um,
E S S Y, um, W H Y, E S S W H Y.
During this event a little bit.
And, uh, he just, he just names everything.
Fuck it.
Like, he did like literally, and I'm just like, Sean, are you going to like, uh,
put that in your POC?
And he's like, fuck it.
Like, I'm just like, okay.
All right.
Like that seems a little bit off, but you know, hey, if it works for you, it works.
Oh my gosh.
That's so amazing.
Yeah.
That doesn't, does not mean it's the good way.
Right.
Yeah.
That's what works, right?
For you at least.
Yeah.
We just, just, yeah.
I mean, that's a great point though, because like, even though we, even though we're all,
you know, towards the, towards the top echelon, um, for POC bounty stuff, it, it doesn't
mean that there's not a lot of improvements that can be made.
So, you know, there's, there's definitely someone up here in the top echelon as well,
that maybe misses some of our gut related stuff,
but also is like organized as frick.
Like, um, I, I, well, yeah, I'll, I'll, I'll shut it out.
Mayonnaise, right?
I've talked to this guy.
Um, you know, he's, he's another guy that's just a legend.
Currently, the yearly number one in the U.S.
Yeah.
Top hacker on HackerOne.
Don't rub it in.
I'm coming for him.
You're in third or second or third.
Third.
Yeah.
Um, but he, uh, he, he's extremely organized, you know, and he has a whole system for organizing
data and he never lets anything fall through the cracks.
And that's just his thing.
Yeah.
And it really helps him.
Um, and so yeah, there, it takes all, all types, I think.
And that's one of the great value add props for Punk Downey is that we all, all different eyes
are needed to secure an attack surface.
And you need some of the, you know, sort of chaotic, more disorganized eyes.
You need the hyper-focused eyes.
You need the absolute lunatics that only do Unicode normalization bugs, Andre.
Yeah, the whole table for it, by the way.
Like you need the, yeah.
And just all people that only do cosmic bugs, you know?
Um, and so yeah, it definitely, it definitely takes all types.
Yeah.
So when, when you're like, as you continue to hack on your main target, um, do you have
any type of like monitoring or automation?
Like how do you know when they come out with new features?
Do you just kind of have your finger on the pulse all the time?
Or how do you, how do you stay up to date and make sure that you're not falling behind with,
with the new features and stuff that they're adding?
Uh, yeah.
So I don't have any like monitoring tooling, uh, the tools I have, okay.
Just like basic, uh, recon and they can, can do data.
So like, I know what's new, but I have to run it like manually.
I have like also a big custom automation tool, but, uh, it doesn't help me figure out
what's new and what's old.
But I'm basically subscribed to the newsletters, different places.
I follow them on Twitter, a lot actually, that actually got me like weird phone bugs.
Wow.
Just like seeing some tweets.
Whoa, we got this, we got that, we got that.
So that's almost like some OSINT level stuff, you know, like you're, you're, you're, you're
watching, you know, you're subscribing to their changelog, their newsletter, their, their Twitter feed.
And then when you see features come up, you know, you have that product level expertise to know,
Oh wait, that's actually sounds really interesting.
And then you dive into that.
Yeah.
They also have like a big releases with the documentation.
And when it's a release, so, uh, I looked, I looked through those.
I'm a little behind now.
Yeah.
Actually.
But, uh, well, yeah, you said, you said lately, you, you don't actually have a ton of,
or at least for this event, the event that you won, you didn't actually have a bunch of time to hack.
Right.
Yeah.
I mean, I, I had like three or four full days and then, um, machine.
I already had planned a vacation with the family.
Yeah.
I went there, uh, but I was, I did like, uh, let's say like five hours in the evening.
In the evening for the, for the night, four to five hours.
Yeah.
And you, you told me before this pod that you, you only really sleep like five or six hours a night.
Is that right?
Yeah.
Ever since the baby, I think, uh, like, around six hours.
Six hours does it for you?
Yeah.
Six hours definitely does it.
Um, do you do, okay.
So there's a clarification there though.
Like, do you wake up after six hours and feel rested or do you wake up after six hours and be like,
okay, I could do my life.
Yeah.
He's like, what is rested?
I have a baby.
Right?
Basically.
Yeah, exactly.
It depends on the baby.
But like, uh, I went to sleep back at one and woke up alone at six and I felt rested like.
Are you, oh wow.
Okay.
Like my, my, my alarm was like at seven.
So when I woke up at six, I was like, okay, fine.
I mean, do you feel like you need a full, am I the only one that needs like actually eight hours of
sleep?
It's, it's really weird.
Actually, like this trip, I've been getting like way less sleep than I normally do.
And I've been feeling more alert than I normally do.
Huh.
And I'm not sure if it's just because of like jet lag or what, but, um, yeah, I, I do wonder
It says that I, I woke him up like 30 minutes before we recorded this podcast by knocking
on his door and calling him like six times.
Yes.
I like, I was having a nice dream.
And then I just hear, John, John, get up.
And then I was like, oh shit.
What time is it?
Justin?
Missed call from Justin.
No, no, no, yeah.
I think, I think, um, yeah, I don't know.
For me, I have to have at least seven hours of sleep.
If it's six, like I can do that for a couple of days, but after that, it starts, you know,
sort of compounding, um, and my brain definitely doesn't work quite as well.
And I have to give it to props to all the European hackers, because like, yeah, you guys come to the
US all the freaking time and jet lag.
And it's, it's pretty bad.
Yeah, we wake up at like two and what?
I slept for four hours.
It's two and much heat and it's really bad.
Yeah.
Do you ever hack, like, do you ever have to like, wake up in the middle of the night
to cure the baby and you just like get an idea and go hack something or?
No.
I will regret it.
And I actually--
Spoken like two people that don't have a baby.
Right?
Yeah.
This hacking in the evening on this vacation was like a super exception for me because I,
I'm not going to never hack in the evening.
Yeah.
So you, you, you, um, you're full-time as well, right?
So we're two full-time hunters here.
And I think for me, one of the things that I've noticed, and maybe you can comment on this
as well, is that I struggle with finding a sense of normal in the midst of the live hacking events.
Right?
Because like, I feel like I sort of live my life from live hacking event to live hacking event.
Like I'm, I'm, so this live hacking event's over.
I'm going to take a couple, uh, you know, a week or two to like chill.
And then either I'm prepping for the next live hacking event.
Oh, and that's another intense period of like, you know, I don't know, maybe 10 hour days,
you know, sometimes more, but you know, but sometimes not.
And, and in the meantime, like I've got enough bandwidth to like do a couple things on the side.
Um, but like most of the time, and my normal gets disrupted every, you know,
every month or two, because I'm doing this big travel.
And, and before that big travel, I'm intensely focused on a target.
So do you, I mean, do you feel that as well?
Do you feel like you have a sense of normalcy in your life?
Uh, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's hard.
It's hard.
I mean, like, uh, yeah, exactly like you, like you said, I also take, usually take time off for
like a week or something, whatever.
Mm-hmm.
Just also spend more time with the baby, because I miss him, dog, wife, or, yeah,
all of those.
Uh, and then I, yeah, basically have to prep for the next event.
But in between, I have to do some other stuff, get that done.
Then comes the event, focus, and gets in the way of maybe other stuff, and yeah, just fly,
and then go back, and yeah, it's, it's, it's pretty hard.
I, I try to just, uh, have, if I'm in between, just have some normal hacking hours in the morning,
and until like, uh, 3:30 or something, or three, with a big, like, lunch, meeting, break.
Yeah, okay.
Yeah, I was just checking to see if they can, if they can hear you.
Yeah, um, so, so you said, you know, normally, you're, you know, you're doing from, from, from,
you know, you've got the live hacking events, but in your normal thing, you're, you're hacking
in the morning, and then you're, you're cutting out at around 3:00 or 3:30.
Yeah, and in between, uh, lunch, lunch break.
Yeah, yeah, it's nice, man.
I, I, I love being a full-time bug bounty hunter, because at the end of the day, you can set your own
schedule pretty freely, and you know, if you do want to go and take a vacation, or, you know, get a,
you know, a long lunch with your wife, or something like that. I don't know, does,
does your wife work from home, or does she go into an office, or what?
Oh, she's a medic, so, she goes in the hospital.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, lovely. Oh, goes to the hospital. Wow, that's, that's a lot then.
No, she's, uh, she's still on the, the, what do you call it, paternity leave or something.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, maternity leave. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Your paternity leave, she's on maternity leave. Oh, that's good.
Okay.
So, you got, man, but your kid's like a year and a half.
Yeah.
Germany's.
What the heck, dude? Germany is nuts.
Meanwhile, in the U.S. they give you like four weeks.
Yeah, the U.S. is like, I'll give you three days.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna need a doctor's note for more than three days.
It's a bit different.
Yeah, I'm sure it is.
Well, that's, that, that is really awesome, though.
But I guess, you know, on the flip side of that, you're paying a lot of taxes on all these bounties, huh?
Yeah.
Yeah, for sure, for sure.
It's, uh, like, you can basically scratch off, like, 45 percent.
Dude, oof.
That, that hurts, that hurts for sure.
Yeah, yeah, for sure.
But yeah, no, it's good to have that, that, that work-life balance in that, um,
and I think that is a struggle for all, full-time.
Actually, you've done full-time for, for longer than me now?
Four years.
Four years, dude, nice.
I'm at, I'm at just, I'm at just over three now, three and a half.
Yeah, I don't actually remember, like, 100 percent.
Yeah.
But I, I think that sounds about the right.
But around four years.
Yeah.
Wow, that's impressive.
So, when you first started hacking, what drew you to your specialty?
Like, what, what drew you towards, like, hacking on that?
Was that something that you were, you had already used at work?
Were you familiar with or something?
Or, like, what, what, like, drew you to focus on that?
It was pure luck.
Okay.
Telling it straight here on Critical Thinking, like.
Yeah, yeah, I got invited pretty, pretty soon.
It is a private program, so I got invited there.
My knowledge was, like, really low, but I found some stuff, so it kind of went, like,
ups, downs, ups, downs, but the trend was, like, going up.
Mm-hmm.
That, that's really interesting, because I feel like with some, with a new program,
sometimes you'll, you'll, you'll get that trend, and then it'll kind of drop back down a little bit,
too, you know, so if you see a very consistent, like, upward trend,
Yeah, exactly.
That might be a good, a good time to say, like, okay, well, this might be my program.
Yeah, yeah, for sure, for sure.
And I didn't, like, do some, that huge planning.
Right, right.
In my mind, because I knew to do it for years.
But it also treated me very well, so I just, like, stick there,
and then when I realized it's full potential, I went, like, deep.
Yeah, I don't know if you can comment on this, but, like, what is the, what is the,
I feel like this program that you hack on has a longer turnaround time than some of the other
programs.
Do you, how do you deal with that, and, yeah.
Uh, so I think, yeah, if you do full-time bug bounty.
Yeah.
I think it's super important to already be stable, like, from a financial point of view.
Like, you should not do it, like, stressed out.
Oh, yeah.
But if it's stress, it's, it's a no-go.
It's terrible.
Yeah, it's terrible.
Yeah.
Uh, so, basically, I just, uh, submit a bug, and then I forget about it.
Mm-hmm.
It's just like that.
Yeah.
Yeah, it can be paid in, like, a few weeks, can be paid a few months,
even more.
But it doesn't really matter to you at that point.
Yeah, exactly.
It doesn't matter.
Like, I think my update requesting is every, like, three to four months.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
Oh, wow.
Geez.
That's, that's pretty intense.
And I think Alex Chapman, Alex Chapman is another hacker that's, that's full-time.
And, uh, and I think he sort of coined the term, or at least he was the first one that I heard
talk about, like, a vulnerability pipeline being important as a full-time hacker.
Yeah.
Because you, or as a full-time bug bounty hunter, because you, you know,
you're not always going to be able to get a quick turnaround on the programs that are going
to give you the best value for your time.
Yes, for sure.
And so, uh, you know, you, you submit the bug and you kind of forget about it, or you have
patience and, you know, you're getting paid today for the bugs you found weeks ago.
And just like has been said, if you're, if you're doing bug bounty in a way that's stressed
out or you're financially tight, then you're, you're going to be needing that payment faster.
And it's going to make you stress.
And it's going to be less able to focus on the program and focus on just sort of chilly
hacking.
And so I think, I think, you know, I I've known this for a little while, you know, this thing
about not being able to do full-time bug bounty stressed out.
But, um, I think it's concreted in my mind now where it's like, if somebody messaged me
and says, Hey, you know, do you think I could do bug bounty and make just a couple of grand?
Cause I really need a couple of grand because you know, X, Y, Z, I'm just going to say literally,
no, it's not an option.
No, you know, just don't do it.
Yeah.
Like go find something that it's going to give you money for time, not money for results.
Right.
Yeah.
Exactly.
Cause we're against the odds.
I've talked about this so many times.
Like bug bounty is literally going against the odds.
You're, you're going against like security teams.
It's like, can I find the things that they missed?
Can I find the things that they did wrong?
Yeah.
And if you don't, then that's like kind of a good thing, but also like, you know,
you can't really follow yourself.
It's not, it's not entirely skill-based.
Yeah.
Some of it that is completely out of your control.
Like there just might not be a bone there.
Yeah.
And you might have just been looking at something for a day and not found anything there.
Cause it's not there.
A little, a little double click into the live hacking event scene.
You know, we have these channels, these Slack channels that we use for the live hacking events.
And one of the most popular channels is the meme channel.
Yeah.
And, and, and like the memes at these events are legendary.
Like every, every time we have, my wife and I have a habit after the event's over,
we just like go back to the, to the, you know, room, sit in the bed and, and go
through all the memes from the, from the live hacking event.
And, and we'll laugh about them.
Um, one of the ones that we saw last night was just this, like, you know, a meme describing the
fact that like, oh, well, you know, there's a bunch of people that are way smarter than me
trying to prevent me from hacking this target all the time, you know, and, and I forget what the format
of the meme was, but it, you know, it kind of hit home and it's something that we talk about a lot.
And I think that it's something that we really can't emphasize enough, you know, in the situation,
because it's all too easy to get into a situation and feel like, man, I just am insufficient.
But no, like you said, a lot of times it's,
there's a whole team designed to, to prevent you from doing what you're trying to do.
Yeah. So back on the topic of like, um, pipe, like pipeline, having a pipeline of bugs and stuff.
Would you say that you submit kind of all across the range of severities or is it like,
do you focus on criticals and highs or where do you draw that line? Because I know a lot of people,
especially full-time hackers, like they want to just have bugs going in so that they can have
money coming back on a regular basis. So it's not like once a month, I submit a crazy bug and I hope
it gets paid in a month because otherwise I'm not getting paid until next month.
Alex, we're looking at you, Alex.
Yeah. So, um, basically doing that, that much time on the same program, I know what they,
what's the third model, what they're interested in, what should I report,
or to like, just take a glance and that's that. Uh, I basically try to submit, uh, impactful bugs,
uh, and I, uh, on the lesser impactful ones, I just look for specific types of those.
Uh, I basically also look, uh, not actively like for XSS, I use like, there's a reflector plugin,
it's really good, uh, with some changes in it.
So you modified the Burr plugin?
Yeah, basically.
Nice.
Then, um, for example, I don't look that much at CSR like anymore, I don't care about it.
Um, I don't do, I don't know, GitHub searches.
Yeah.
I don't do, I've never ever done a subdomain takeover in my life.
Uh, I, I mean like, there are lots of like better people with all the proper tools to do everything.
So it just, no, I basically try to focus on some specific things.
Uh, and then, yeah.
Yeah, do you, do you do chaining then?
Like, do you, do you, do you ever, so, you know, you're submitting all sorts of types of vulns,
but do you ever say like, okay, I've got this vuln that can be a medium, but I know how to chain,
I know that this is a helpful gadget to chain it into a higher crit, um, within the context of this program.
Do you ever save those vulns and, and not report them until later?
No.
No?
Because, um, chaining, uh, in this particular program is very good.
Yeah.
But usually the core of the issue is the one that's actually impactful.
Uh, and the one that's actually good.
And they recognize this.
Uh, no, I recognize that from their pattern and stuff like that.
Uh, like, for, for, for, for instance, I just once in, uh, and, uh, I think it was an SSRF,
an open redirect, and the open redirect was already reported.
Uh, they were good enough to, uh, pay part of the award, but because like, part of the chain was not there,
didn't matter that much, because actually that wouldn't have opened without that open redirect.
And even if it's an open redirect, this is maybe not that good of an example because it's like niche.
But for example, for XSS is like, you know, from starts in this particular program, what's the severity?
Right, right, right.
Yeah.
So that's that I don't like you have, if you have like a specific proof of concept to an account
takeover, it's fine.
You can use it, but that's not like a bargain itself.
So, and change very quickly.
I, uh, okay.
So it's mostly just classic volumes for you.
You know, it's not necessarily that you're, that you're like, okay, I've got this sort of flow
figured out where if I can, you know, let's just say, for example, I can set a header in the
response or something like that.
It results in some sort of crazy thing.
It's, it's very, very involved types and, and, you know, not even crazy amounts of chains.
Uh, yes and no.
Like I know a lot of niche interesting stuff that are not vulnerable in itself,
but helps the record process a lot.
Right.
Like very small things.
Like, uh, when you ping a site and do a post request on HTTP instead of HTTPS.
Right, right, right.
It's already directed to some interesting stuff.
Interesting.
Like very small things.
Yeah.
I know to hit like a specific path that stops at the load balancer level.
It doesn't go through.
So it's extremely fast.
Stuff like that.
This is you're walking us through your, your, your tricks.txt.
Yeah, cat tricks.txt.
That's already written in tools.
So it's nothing more.
Yeah, no, that's, that's, that's in my head.
This is very often.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
And I think that, but I mean, we make fun of his little tricks.txt thing,
but actually that, that, that is pivotal, you know, that, that is absolutely pivotal
to, to staying at a target long-term.
I have one target that I've done, you know, not even close to long, as long-term as, as,
you know, what you've done.
But, um, you know, even on that, you start to put the, when you start to piece things together
and you start understanding these little quirks that just tell you a little bit about
how a certain functionality is flowing and that functionality is present across their whole scope.
It makes all the difference because you, you, you can get that little better.
It, well, it informs the gut, right?
Right.
You know, when you're talking about the gut earlier and it, it informs the gut and it allows you to
get that, that sort of, and even if it's just subconscious.
It's like a spidey sense.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Your, your spidey sense, but you know, there has to be something that signals it, right?
And in some of the times it can be those, those little tricks.
So that, that's, that's really cool.
Yeah.
I would imagine that like there are certain keywords, right?
Or like things that like you notice, because you don't only hack directly on that target.
You hack on other companies that will use that, the technologies or, or, you know,
will integrate with it.
And I, I can imagine that there are certain things that you've noticed that are like,
Oh, they're using that.
I, now I know.
Yeah.
And then you just narrow, like focus in and just dive in and you, you start to fiddle with things
and try and find endpoints that you can manipulate that, you know, how they work and that kind of stuff.
Yeah.
That, that, that for sure.
Like you recognize, like you said, all the keywords, the patterns,
the, the, everything, you know, how it's like, you can imagine pretty well how it's done in the
background or the backend.
Yeah.
Um, yeah.
I also like build a ton of like custom word lists.
Oh, that's interesting.
Nice.
Yeah.
I think it's super good.
Like I had some amazing results with a specific word is that this is not big.
Like it's truly has like 10,000 words or something.
Oh, how are you building that?
Are you, are you scraping, you know, JS files or map files or text on the thing or?
Or is this wordless.txt?
Or is this the seventh file?
Cat note.txt tokenize into, oh no.
I think, uh, this is a pretty important piece of my, uh, secret sauce.
Okay.
Because if I tell you once, everybody can actually do it.
Because it's, uh, I've never actually read a documentation like anywhere like this technique.
Right.
And kind of, but not.
Yeah.
You know, and that's, that's the cool thing about, you know, having people come on, on
the pod and being in the bug bounty community as well is that there, there are things that
you, you share and things that you, you know, feel like you can give back to the community,
but also like you have to, you have to keep some of that stuff because it's so competitive.
And I talk to people about the industry fairly often.
Right.
And they're like, why would anybody ever share anything?
Like, and cause it's like, you're literally creating opponents here.
You're creating people that will, that will steal bounties, steal, literally steal money.
Yeah.
Right.
And, uh, but I think that's part of the beauty and that dynamic is really interesting because
in general, I think it's a really collaborative environment.
Um, and, and we, in general, we really lift each other up, but you know,
but it's, it's also, uh, uh, another point, like another point of view here.
Yeah.
Like if you have all those resources, it's very good.
Like when I started, there was not that many resources at all, but then you like, you have
like maybe five to 10 super good resources and you use that one and nobody actually innovates
any stuff.
Like what I did was like, never, ever read a blog post on that in my life in the beginning.
Yeah.
Like ever.
So it kind of like focuses you to think a bit for yourself outside the box, like two sides of the coin.
Yeah.
That that's, that's super, super important and really well said.
I think that you, you can get lost.
You know, we talked about this a little bit on the, what was that episode that I just like
made up a bunch of words that were like Dr. Seuss.
I forget what that was.
Oh yes.
The, the, oh man, what was it?
The, the beginner tips or something.
Yeah.
Well, we'll, we'll link it in the description or whatever.
We'll call it, you know, Justin's weird episode with all the Dr. Seuss.
With the rhymes.
Yeah.
Um, but yeah, you know, it's so easy to get caught up in the education piece, especially
with all the resources now.
And we say like, oh, you know, I wish I had all these resources when I had just started,
but, but actually maybe it's better.
Right.
You know, maybe it is, maybe it's better that you had to get your hands in there and figure
it out for yourself in a lot of ways.
Um, because then you, you do figure out how to develop methodologies and it takes more time
and it takes a little bit of a grind for sure.
Because I've seen, I've seen hackers go from zero to like finding crits on hardened programs
in like less than two years, you know, with the resources of two months.
Yeah.
I mean, true.
Some people just really intake it quick depending on the background, but I've seen someone literally
go, uh, I'll call it out.
So, um, my, my, my mentee.
So he, he went from, you know, French major to finding crits, you know, in, in less than two
years, like on, on his own, you know, and, and, uh, and, you know, it's definitely possible
with the resources, but also, you know, a big part of our, our flow, you know, working together
to help him grow as a hacker was doing, doing a lot of hacking.
Yeah.
And then we would, you know, maybe we would do five or six hours of hacking together in a day.
And then he would go home and read five hours of resources.
Yeah.
Right.
And so he was really putting in the time, um, and those resources are great, but it has to be,
has to be, has to be, has to be accompanied with failing.
Right.
You've got to get out there and fail and, and, you know, develop your own techniques because
that's where you get the secret sauce like this, that, that, that Cosman has.
That's, that's, that's super clutch.
So I guess one of the other things that I had on the list for you regarding a specific,
you know, working with one specific, uh, program over the longterm is your relationship with the
team.
Like how has your relationship with the team evolved and how have you, um, how has that helped
you as, as a hacker or as a participant in that program?
So, um, I've always had a very good relationship with the whole team.
Yeah.
Uh, even if they, they change the management, new employees or so on, um, because I, I always
felt appreciated by them.
Uh, and what I said was like impactful, it was probably analyzed.
I, uh, I never felt like tweaked or stuff like that.
So it was like, I think it's also a very mutual, it's full of mutual respect.
Hmm.
And also, yeah, when they needed something for me, I was there for them.
Right.
When I needed something from, from them, they were there for me.
Yeah.
So it's, it's pretty important.
That, that, that's really good.
I, I will say, you know, and I imagine that takes a lot of effort on your behalf as well,
because especially with the, you know, report a bug and forget it mentality.
Like sometimes you, you'll report a bug, you know, month will pass and they'll be like,
Hey, um, clarifying detail on this.
And I'm like, I don't even remember where that was, you know, and you got to go back
and like figure it out, like all the different details about it.
So that takes work.
Uh, I, I don't, I don't think this ever happened.
What?
Yeah.
Ever.
Because they have, um, a specific trash team.
Like they, they own trash team and they are accustomed to the product.
Yeah.
So when they have questions, they do it like beforehand and then go through some,
I don't know what the back end, that process looks like.
I have no idea.
Yeah.
However, they give all the details and, uh, maybe like two or three times.
That's like clarifications.
How I found something like, how I reached a result, but this is not like a technical question.
Wow.
That's, that's, that's actually really, that's really amazing because, you know,
I feel like, especially as remediation starts to come into effect, a lot of times I get another
question like, Hey, could we fix this by this?
And then I'm like, uh, not really sure.
Cause I don't remember any of the details of this bug.
Um, and, and so it seems like they've got a lot of technically competent people on the back end
that don't even necessarily need to double check with you.
You know, they can just kind of look, look at the code, talk to their own, you know,
security team and figure that out.
So that's cool.
Yeah.
And if you can bypass it, great.
You know, like there's another bounding for you.
Yeah.
So when you find, when you're, when you submit bugs to other programs that are outside
of the main thing that you hack on, but are like usually, usually using that technology,
would you say that it's something that you have found on the, on the main technology and then gone
to check if it's on other programs or is it, you're just curious.
You're looking at that program.
You stumble on the technology and you're like, oh, okay, let's, let's exploit this.
Uh, yeah.
So, and I've, I've never consciously like, uh, sent a report on a program that uses the
technology when I knew that that was a core issue, um, because they truly thrown upon that.
So that's like a big, like a huge no, and if I find something that happened, uh, like maybe
two times, you'll find something on a program that uses the technology.
And I'm not sure whether that's like a configuration thing or it's a core issue.
I can test it on something that I own and to see that's a core issue.
So I know exactly where to submit it.
Nice.
Oh my gosh.
That, that must take so much effort though, because you got to go reset up that whole project.
Yeah.
So for yourself.
Do you do a lot of testing on like a local instance or whatever that you
have configured and set to defaults?
Yeah.
I have a lot of, uh, various testing instances.
Nice.
Different purposes.
All called ASDF.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
ASDF1, ASDF2.
Basically, I usually spin a new one if like I'm out of storage.
Or, or if the name is taken.
It was funny because you were, during one of your show tells, you were, you were showing
like the configuration that you had used or whatever for like your, just like a setup or
something and there was like city, name.
Oh, I love that.
That's, that's, that's actually me, uh, like trying, you know?
Usually it's ASD, ASD, ASD, ASD.
Yeah, and there was an address and it was, it was street.
Yes, with E's.
City.
Yeah, so, so you can, you can like actually realize it's not like a placeholder.
Right, right, right, right.
Street, city, Arkansas.
That was a drop down.
That doesn't drop down.
We, we both knew it was Arkansas because we're both like, what?
Yeah, I was like, Cosmic, Arkansas?
Arkansas.
Of all the states in the U.S., Arkansas.
That's just A drop down, you know?
Yep, A-R.
Exactly.
Oh my gosh.
City, Nevada or Alaska.
That's, that's hilarious, man.
Yeah, no, I forgot, yeah, I didn't even, I kind of forgot that that was a state.
Oh man, yeah, no, that's, that's great.
Um, cool, man.
Let me see, let me see what else I've got on the list here because we had a great, we've
had a great conversation so far.
Um, yeah, uh, so I guess we talked a decent bit about what it means to be on, on one target
for the long term.
The last thing that I had was like, how do you create mental models or do you intentionally
create mental models for how a product works and do you store those in your, you know, notes.txt or do
you kind of keep them all up in your head just architecturally and also like structurally?
So here, um, I can definitely recognize I have a problem.
Keep them in my head.
Uh-huh.
Yeah.
I forget it.
Then I have to re-realize how it works.
Yeah.
And then maybe I edit in the text file.
I give this hat.
So yeah, uh, I actually went like to...
Cosman's doing like ASCII art in his, like frogs.
That's exactly how I feel.
Every time I come back to a program that I haven't touched in like a while.
Yeah.
I'm like, oh, and then it all clicks.
I'm like, oh God, I remember it now.
Yeah.
Exactly.
Something like, something like that.
Um, I went like to the same parts of the app multiple times and I know that was not efficient,
not good.
It was kind of frustrating sometimes because you don't find the results.
You know, it's there.
We just like forgot that specific URL.
Sure.
Uh, but I usually remember how I got this.
Yeah.
I remember the process.
And I think you, you told me before this event that you've actually seen a decent
amount of the targets that were in scope, you know, before.
And so it's, it's pretty, it's pretty clear, you know, that the, you can come back.
You mentioned earlier.
I mean, it was really interesting that you, you said you'll, you'll hit a mental block
and then you'll, you'll come back, you know, later afterwards.
And that's really like, that does not work at all for me.
Like for me, I've got to be, I've got to hit a mental block and then just iterate again.
And then iterate again while I've got it all in my brain.
Right.
And then, you know, really, if I'm like really, really stuck and something's close,
maybe I'll like force myself to move along and, but still be thinking about it in like
a background process.
But like, I don't move, move along very easily and then come back to something.
And it seems like that's something that you do.
So that's an interesting tip.
Yeah.
So I do that, like you said, but I also have to hit a block.
Like if I'm in the zone, I'm not like switching targets or anything.
But if I exhaust like the things I wanted to try, I maybe move to something else, then
maybe come back, especially in lifehacking events, because I'm, I picked
something like pretty shallow.
Yeah.
So it does not, and I just like went there.
So I could actually afford to ping pong a bit.
Ah, nice.
Yeah.
So also like on the big thing that I do, I do the same thing.
Because sometimes I actually miss things or have like a new fresh idea that works.
Yeah.
Like later you notice some weird behavior.
I wonder if that's good.
Exactly.
So I think it's pretty important to know what's going on, like mentally how you do it,
how you achieve that result, like the whole process, but maybe it's not that important
to know all the details if you know how to get the details again.
Yeah.
I don't know if it makes sense.
Yeah, no, that definitely makes sense.
I think it's, I think like you said, intuitively, that's not the most efficient
flow.
Well, I think maybe even going through that exercise of rediscovering.
Yeah, exactly.
The, the functionality can firm up your understanding because it's almost like you're coming back
with semi fresh eyes, right?
You know, like if I have a problem with something, I'll hit up Joel and Joel will come look at it.
He's got a fresh set of eyes.
He sees something different.
Right.
But you know, maybe if I don't hit up Joel and I spend a couple of days, you know,
do something else and I come back to it, you know, my eyes are sort of not as, as fresh with it.
And maybe I'll see something different as well.
That sounds, it seems like what you're doing.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, exactly.
So what you're telling me is I can cut Joel out of the bounty process.
Wait, wait, wait, hold on.
Hold on a second.
Maybe I don't even need Joel anymore.
Critical thinking with Justin only.
All right, we're starting Joel's critical thinking.
No, no, shoot.
No, that's, that's a great tip.
That's a, that's a really solid one.
And also like, between those processes, you also learn new, new things that on the second iteration,
you can apply them also there.
And it's actually kind of built also in my tools.
My tools reiterate their own previous results from other places and try to do that again in a new environment.
And actually like have results.
Like if you have my, the tool that I have in a blank new machine.
Yeah.
It will not have like many hits.
But if you like reiterate on a big like data, it kind of like tries to do the same stuff again.
And like.
It's really interesting to hear, hear like other hackers describe this.
Because I think it's almost like you have your own little internal, like live hacking event.
Where you're knowledge sharing with yourself.
Yeah, like, like.
It's like, it's so weird.
Because every time we go to a live hacking event and like, if you're collaborating with someone,
they'll be like, hey, I have this really weird behavior.
And I find that nine times out of 10, I'll be like, oh, have you tried this, this, this?
And they're like, yeah, I tried all of that stuff.
Didn't work.
And I was like, oh man.
Okay, so we're thinking about this the same way.
You know how Kozman like scrolls up in notes that takes tea?
Hey, Pastor Kozman.
Guess what?
I have this weird behavior.
Maybe you can figure it out.
Thanks.
You know, like, oh my gosh.
Sharing tips with yourself.
Next level shit right there.
You know, people are coming into this, this interview, you know.
It's, it's Kozman.
He's going to have some crazy shit.
Just sitting at home talking to himself.
Kozman's like, I've got this mirror, right?
I talked to the mirror.
Hey, Kusman, you guys have got updated.
Let's go.
Oh my gosh.
You guys are, you guys are too much, man.
Yeah.
All right.
Well, I mean, that's, that's all I had on my list.
Do you have any, any, I guess, let me ask this.
Do you have any tips or tricks?
I think you're the leading expert that I can think of on staying on one program
for a long-term and making a shit ton of money on it.
Like, do you have any, any tips for, for people that relate to long-term relationship
building with one program?
And would you recommend that to all hackers?
Yeah.
I think everybody has its own way.
There are different types of people that some, some go wide, some go deep, some focus on specific
vulnerability times.
They're all very successful.
Yeah.
So in the scope of a question for me personally, it was a very fortunate and good to go this
spot and having a good relationship with the program, I think it's crucial.
Yeah.
And, but that can be seen pretty fast.
Like after a few months, I think you can actually get an idea of what's happening and you could decide
for yourself whether to proceed that program or just to stop.
Because if you feel like you're being tricked or not appreciated, you cannot do it long term, I think.
Yeah.
Um, I, I have a little interesting perspective on this as well, because, um, I've been on the
company side, I've actually been on the company side that you've reported stuff to as well.
Yeah, it's true.
And, um, and I think certain researchers really demonstrate like just in how they report and what
they report, like the type of like person that they are, the type of hunter they are and the type of
relationship that they're trying to build.
And so like, if you're submitting critical stuff and like, you're doing your best to be like open,
honest and transparent about that and you're consistent, right?
It's more like, once you get two or three reports into a program, they know your name.
Like they're going to know it, especially if those are really good, well-written reports.
And that's like what you do.
Right.
And so like, I don't think I've ever seen a report from you that's been like, oh, this, this report sucks.
Like I can't even read this, right?
Because like you, you have a reputation and that reputation holds up.
So I think it's important, not only from like the program side, the program side will probably
pick up on it.
Like once you start reporting because they see that you're interested and they're like,
oh, awesome.
This person is, is actively like hacking system.
Yeah.
You know, we want them to keep going.
Like we want to keep seeing bugs from this person.
And that's like an awesome thing to see as a program.
It's just like somebody who's finding cool shit that you've missed.
Yeah.
I think you've mentioned in the past too, that you, you have, like, I remember you saying
like, ah, this, this one bug is like 20 steps long.
Right.
And I'm like, and I'm like, man, I don't know that I've ever written a report.
It's like, you know, 15 steps long.
Right.
So I think probably there's a lot of detail that goes into your reports too.
Uh, yeah.
So this is actually a skillset you have to develop for yourself to learn to write a good report.
It's extremely, extremely important.
Yeah.
It cuts out of frustration.
Faster turnaround times and everything.
Yeah.
It's really good.
Do you do video POCs?
Uh, I almost always do video POCs.
If it's some, somehow like complex, if it's like an XSS, I put a screenshot.
Yeah.
Same.
That's that.
But if it's like something complex, uh, I do a video POC, but I also realized that
it's extremely important to properly write the application steps because nobody wants to like
open a video in a new screen or something and then just like, uh, yeah, I have to do that.
Let me pause the video video.
Oh, what did you do there?
Rewind.
Yeah.
How can I copy this?
I cannot copy this.
Or like copying the video into 16 different ticket programs you've got inside of a,
you know, JIRA and this and that.
So yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
So both parts are important.
And I, I, I usually have like a really structured report.
Um, I have a summary, describes the vulnerability a bit and it's a new program.
I tend to like give explanations about like why this is happening.
Sometimes in some rare cases, uh, I give documentation like links.
Uh, site, site documentation back to them.
Yeah.
And then like the replication steps, uh, I, I write down video or screenshot attached
and the impact section I write impacting does that.
So yeah.
I feel like, especially for other teams that aren't the main program that you're, that you're
on, like a lot of the time they don't even fully understand like the technology that you're
hacking on.
And so it's like difficult for them to know why it's a security impact.
So I think that's really important for like you who has really, really deep understanding of
like, why is this bad and how it's bad and that this is like a default configuration or something
like that to explain to the security team so that they can understand it because oftentimes
it's an engineering focus that the engineering team has chosen to use this technology and it's
more convenient for them.
But the security team isn't in on that decision.
Right.
They're just there as the security team.
And then they find out later that it's been done improperly.
Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
Yeah.
That's so, okay.
So we've got, you know, being consistent, you've got writing, writing really solid reports.
And then you said within the first like two or three months, you'll kind of know whether the team
is like some, somebody you'd want to work with continuously.
Besides those three, do you have any other tips for people wanting to develop along to find their,
you know, bread and butter program, their program that they're going to stick with long term?
What other kind of tips and indicators do you have?
You have to like hacking.
I think it's extremely important.
Yeah, that makes total sense.
I have some technologies that I totally dislike when I see them.
And I usually just close the program.
But I can also afford to do that now and just like move to something else.
I didn't, don't even start.
But surely you dislike this program, you know, sometimes.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
That happens.
Do you, okay.
So, you know, would you say that there are periods of like, you know, a week?
Or would you say that there are periods of a couple of days where you're like,
oh man, like I am really sloshing through this right now.
Like, I really don't want to be doing this.
Like, you know, how long do you think those periods last versus like the,
the eventual come around, which is like, ah, you know what, actually, this is pretty good.
Uh, it kind of, I know it's hard to quantify, but yeah.
So if I have like a disagreement or something, um, yeah, not necessarily with the program,
but like with the technology, like, do you, do you ever like.
Do you get burned out basically.
What?
Oh yeah.
Well, okay.
It's not even burned out.
Like do you, well, maybe sort of, but like, do you ever think like,
ah, I really don't like hacking this technology right now, or is it pretty.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Okay.
I understand what you mean.
Yeah.
Uh, this happens.
This happens.
Yeah.
Uh, it happened already numerous times.
And I just, uh, try to hack something else.
And that's the point when sometimes I switch to other programs that I hack.
But usually I just see if I have some interesting invites, like to start somewhere fresh.
So you bounce, bounce out for just a second.
And maybe the live hacking events, you can help with this.
Uh, yeah, yeah, for sure.
For sure.
Yeah.
Those, those, those, those actually help.
If it's a live hacking event, I just focus on that.
So it's like nothing else.
Yeah, I just bounce out a little, bounce in between.
And then usually come back to see if like something new.
I have another idea.
What does my text file says?
Yeah.
What does my text file say?
Do you have like an ideas.txt as well?
Oh my gosh.
You keep like things that are kind of interesting, but maybe not fully formed.
Yeah.
That's part of notes.
Got it.
Oh man.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
That's great.
I mean, that, that's really odd.
You know, you'd think it's obvious advice, but I think for people that are highly motivated
and people that really want to succeed, they just try to like, you know, just make it happen.
Right.
And, and I think that's one of the things, and this is applicable to life too.
It's not just bug bounty is like, you ought to like the thing you're trying to succeed in,
you know, and if you don't, maybe you should switch.
Because at the end of the day, um, if you don't like it at a lower level,
it's going to be really hard for you to push through long term.
Yep.
And in, and just a little bit of liking it, I think that's a long way too.
Yeah.
You know?
Yes.
Yeah.
It's exactly what we talked about with like, when like beginners try to pick their first
program.
Yeah.
Like I always say like, just pick like something that you're, that like you use on a daily basis,
or that you like, you, you think it's a cool technology, or like when you read the company
name, you're like, I'll be epic if I could hack the US Department of Defense.
Right.
It's like, just pick something that like seems interesting to you and set that goal for
yourself because that like, that genuine attraction towards the product, towards the, towards the
program is going to drive you to like, try and find those epic bugs.
Right.
Like you want to like find something super epic.
Maybe it's for bragging rights, but also just for like, you know, I hacked the DoD or I hacked
whatever.
Right.
It's like, it's like functional, it's a functional objective.
Yeah.
Right.
It's really important.
Yeah.
No, that's great.
It just makes me think of that, that thing we were laughing about the other day in one of the
hacker chats we're in of like, um, did someone release like a, a list of like top 100 most
secure companies or something like that.
And we're like, oh no, like, why would you do this?
And, and some, you know, some hacker out there is definitely going to be like,
There's my, there's my top 10 list.
Yeah.
And I'm going to pwn all of these, you know, for the next.
No, that's good.
That, that definitely makes sense.
And, and I'm sure there's lots of complex intricacies to developing, you know, your,
your bread and butter program.
You know, we heard, we heard lots of documentation.
We heard good reports.
We heard like the product.
We heard, you know, value your relationship with the, with the company.
Yeah.
Step away when you're not feeling it.
Bounce, bounce away when you're not feeling it and then come back to it and, and check
and see whether that, that, that feeling of love, you know, is still there for the program.
And I love that nuance because it's like, you know, you can
be like, I mean, you're like the most quintessential,
like single program hacker that I can think of.
Yeah.
And yet you still take breaks from the program.
You just switch it up.
You still do different stuff.
And like, you're still able to go back and like crush it.
Like regularly because of all those other things that you're doing,
like taking breaks and taking notes and writing good reports
and having that relationship with the team.
Yeah.
Or sometimes it also helps like, uh, building around tools around something.
You know, uh, as a break or, uh, also as a break.
Yes.
Um, then also you have to think about, well, what can I add to that?
And you can research into that, uh, area particularly.
And you learn a little bit more and then you can automate it.
Maybe just integrate it in a flow or whatever works for you.
Yeah.
Nice.
But I think you can't take these breaks if you're stressed out about money.
Yeah.
Right.
Exactly.
Yeah, it definitely does.
It's definitely someone that, you know, you need to be in a,
in a financially secure position to be able to commit to a program long-term like this.
Yeah.
For sure.
And, and so, you know, this particular program that you work on,
you know, there, there are a couple of hackers that, that, you know,
have this as their main thing.
So do you ever see a decent amount of overlap with other hackers?
Do you, I mean, like, what would you say your dupe ratio is in this program?
Three percent?
Three, three, three percent.
Okay.
That was maybe the most German response ever.
Not one percent.
Yeah.
Three percent.
Like, I said, like, five was too much, one was too little.
Yeah, so it's like three percent.
Yeah.
Really, we, we do various, very different, uh, stuff.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
Lot has been like that since the, since the beginning.
I think it's, it's not that important to look at the, thank you, so.
Sure.
Yeah.
The activity or whatever at the top.
We, we, we talk about that all the time, you know,
people get scared away by that little, that little, you know,
top hackers in this program thing.
Yeah.
Everyone has different eyes, man.
And if I recall correctly, you're not even number one on this program.
No.
There's somebody else who is.
Yeah.
It's crazy, which is, I can't even fathom.
Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
So like you said, everybody is different.
Yeah.
Has their own way.
And yeah, just go in if you like it.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Wow.
Great, great tips, man.
Um, Kazmin, thank you so much for coming on the pod.
Thanks for having me.
Um, yeah, I, I will definitely have to pick your brain again sometime.
Maybe next time you win a belt.
We'll see.
Yeah.
Awesome.
All right.
Thanks, man.
Thank you.
That's fun.
It's fun.